for more than a year the devastating war
in ethiopia's tigre region has consumed
africa's second most populous nation
jeffrey feltman the u.s special envoy to
the horn of africa has met with
ethiopia's prime minister to resolve the
fighting on friday the un security
council called for peace and for the
access of humanitarian aid just about
one million people live in famine-like
conditions in the region as the fighting
fuels the world's worst hunger crisis in
a decade deborah potter reports
we will bury this enemy with our blood
and bones
it's hard to imagine these are the words
of a nobel peace prize winner that's
ethiopia's prime minister abi ahmed
marking one year since he sent his
troops in to crush the rebellious tigray
region since then his standing as a
peacemaker who won the nobel prize for
ending the war with eritrea has been
undermined abi's troops together with
eritrean soldiers are accused of
committing unspeakable atrocities
massacres gang rape and ethnic cleansing
the united nations calls them war crimes
and stresses they have been committed on
both sides of the conflict they kill us
they kill us not we kill them they kill
us
and at the center of it all innocent
civilians staring down a deepening
humanitarian crisis over 900 000 people
at risk of starvation hunger used as a
weapon of war as food aid convoys have
been blocked
the immediate trigger for the military
conflict was tigre's decision to hold an
unauthorized poll in 2020 after abi
postponed the country's elections and in
november last year he sent the ethiopian
military into tigray claiming he was
responding to an attack on a government
military camp
since then the fighting has seen
devastating casualties with as many as
several hundred thousand dead now there
are fears that the tigrayan soldiers
could advance on addis ababa after they
captured two cities near the capital and
joined forces with eight other
anti-government factions the u.s embassy
in ethiopia has warned its citizens to
leave the country without delay for cbs
saturday morning debra pada johannesburg
south africa